jack dorsey square block and cash app
they're rolling out bitcoin's lightning
network to tens of millions of users by
integrating the lightning network into
cash app now for those of you that don't
know what the lightning network is it's
a layer two solution that simply makes
bitcoin much cheaper and much faster to
use you can basically send bitcoin to
anyone in the world without asking
permission of anybody else now there's
tons and tons of p2p payment solutions
that are out in the marketplace
everything from paypal to venmo to cash
app and many others but of course if i
have paypal and you don't i can't send
you money same is true with venmo or
cash app i have to have the same app
that you have but now that's all
changing the bitcoin network and the
lightning network these are
interoperable open systems meaning that
as long as cache app supports the
lightning network anyone else on the
lightning network can now send bitcoin
to a cache app user and vice versa so
now if cache app and venmo will support
the lightning network a cache app user
can send bitcoin to a venmo user this is
a very big deal and so ultimately having
cash app go ahead and integrate the
lightning network that means that they
are going to onboard 70 million
different users to bitcoin's lightning
network so think about that that's
almost 20 of the us population that is
how you usher in mass adoption very very
quickly and so ultimately whether you
want to actually send bitcoin to
somebody else on the cash app or send it
to somebody else on the lightning
network whether you want to actually buy
a good or a service using bitcoin or you
simply want to move money around the
world without asking permission of a
third party or a rent seeker cash app
now will let you do that i believe every
single payment solution in the world
whether it's a legacy point of sale
system or it's a peer-to-peer payment
system they are all going to integrate
with the lightning network there is no
other system in the world where you can
send one penny instantaneously
completely for free to anyone in the
world bitcoins payment rails are simply
superior to anything else that was built
in the legacy world and when you have
superior technology when you have a
network effect and you have growth and
scale this quickly it's impossible to
ignore kudos to cash app i like to see
them leading from the front bitcoin's
lightning network is inevitable it
continues to grow at an incredible pace
and cache app is just pouring fuel on
the fire bitcoin's lightning network is
going to be the dominant payment system
globally and this is just another step
in that march